Final Fantasy 15 those fancy phones but
looking forward to this bad boy for a
long time looks like they won't have to
wait that much longer alexa ray korea
Peter Brown and his super loud laptop
were here on what's going on there
what's going on blazing up there yeah
yep that word is really pushing this
core i7 processor is fry an egg on that
bad boy and Final Fantasy 15 excited
yeah excited yeah tell me about what
happened at Gamescom you an interview a
gentleman who might have been making
that game and he might have slipped a
little bit of details to you yeah Hajime
Tabata is the director of finance to
type 0 and now Final Fantasy 15 he took
over the verses 13 project back in 2012
and then mated 15 and yeah we spoke a
lot about where the game is how long
we're gonna have to wait to play it and
this came after a presentation that him
and his team gave at games come which
was very lackluster in terms of new
information they brought all this great
stuff and they what they showed a short
story trailer they revealed an enemy and
showed a main character whose name is
the black haired girl i mean mr. name
right they call her this drape like
black hair girl i am as in her hair is
straight hair straight ok um I have to
say I've been waiting for this game for
10 years that presentation inspired no
confidence in me that that game is
coming out yeah next year at all they
have a character that they refer to
internally by her hair color so she's
have a name they still don't know I
talked to Tabata as well back in January
he said you know airships were working
on the technology we don't know if we
can do it they said the same thing at
Gamescom they said well we can get him
the high that the height that a bird
would fly but we don't really know and
they showed what enemy which looks like
it's in an area very similar to what
we've seen in episode does this the
enemy is he gonna meet some Alvaro Oh a
final fantasy staple and um they didn't
the trailer was two and a half minutes
of a guy holding his kid what's your
watch anything but that kid looks so
real and it was a great look so good
great also that guy it's [ __ ] raining
man like don't hold your kid out get
your kid damn
I'm like I don't know like the trailer
was just some places that's a straight
girl because I think they have to redo
that texture um I don't know the fact
that there's a main character without a
name and there's we've seen very little
new areas and that they don't know
whether or not that can use the
technology that they have available to
them to make something work uh 10 years
into the dev psychol I don't I don't
know I'm skeptical that would contradict
what that we heard spoken horses Matt
Peter and so you asked him when events
will see it he said I can definitely
tell you it's not this year and then he
rambled on a bit and he said I can
certainly tell you you don't have to
wait until 2017 mmm so now obviously you
know that says 2016 we put up the story
saying that square didn't jump down our
throats or anything PR double check
before we printed it so you know we're
good you know one of the things that
people are sort of a trying to wrap
their head around is the different
percentages that to body gives out right
at TGS last september's said the game
was fifty fifty-five percent on at
Gamescom during his presentation he said
65 oh so that makes it sound like you
know ten percent a year early access
right but 2016 so I asked him you know
what have you done over the last year
and he was like all right before we talk
about what's been happening over the
last year let me just clear up the thing
about the numbers I said normally when
we describe it we think like in terms of
numbers we think about internally as how
long have we got until the mastering of
the game okay right so if you think
about that that's sixty-five percent
until the game is actually like printed
right so 2012 to now that would be what
that's like three years maybe a handful
of months yeah so if you think about you
give it another year like let's say a
year and a half right just to be fair I
gave it to December that could happen
without those percentages but when he's
talking about the actual content of the
game itself he told me that it's over
seventy percent what so it's like
sixty-five percent ready to print but
what's in the game is seventy percent
done trying so in terms of a sort of the
assets of the programming the things
that the things that we're missing here
are first of all you need to localize
the game this is and I'm sort of
spoiling a news story we're going to put
up this is the first
final fantasy game that they are
planning to release simultaneously
worldwide oh wow way yes dude breaking
news yes Ashley yeah somehow they still
have to do all the localization in that
regard and they still have to like
master all the discs right and ship
those out all over the world you got
ready to go QA perhaps as part of that
as well as part of that right so yeah
the content stuff is worrisome when
they're talking about airships maybe
being a thing maybe not but he did say
that it could come as DLC and and just
this morning they were talking about
perhaps working with the apt Evelyn
studios and to sort of get their their
tech from Just Cause to give the game
greater verticality now implementing
tech from one engine to another is not
really something you can do overnight I
I think he was probably saying something
along the lines of we've had these
thoughts we're having those discussions
but look I don't expect they're going to
put airships in before this game of
ships I asked a bottle why are you the
right man for the job after so many
years and people have so many concerns
why should they trust you and he said
that my strongest skill is setting a
timeline and optimizing a team getting
things done with certain goals in mind
and then proceeding forward so it sounds
like he is a very like you know strict
militant approach to how he's managing
this project project when you compare
that to Nomura who blessed his heart is
a recluse is known for not communicating
well with his teams and works on like
six major projects at a time Tabata is
yeah like Tabata is in a great position
to actually buckle down say all right
deep breath mm-hmm here's when we want
to ship the game here the milestones we
need to hit for every aspect of the game
let's just rally together and do it well
sound good everybody it sounds great
also let's get Rico Rodriguez in this
game just really i got um here's my
question no no no if you talk to him
about this but something else that sort
of makes me really skeptical about this
is they released dusk a the first one
mmm three months later they released
dusk a two-point no and dusk a two-point
o's combat was so different they fixed
the targeting they fixed a lot of other
stuff they fix speed and then they added
a bunch of attacks so the fact that they
went back and then changed all of the
combat based on player feedback in this
to our demo
like based on if the game is done at all
would they go back and change all of the
combat in the game like is that simple
to do is that hard like why did they do
that I mean so combat is obviously
taking place like in a broad range of
environments against many different
enemies but at its core it really is a
singular system that has variables that
can be tweaked so even if they've got
combat set for the entire game like
let's just pretend all the environments
are made maybe you don't have textures
all the combat scenarios are there one
tweak to the system will come into
effect across the entire game so if
they're using episode dust gay as sort
of a focus test you know sample right to
kind of get people's opinions they can
tweak something and although we only see
it reflected in that small demo that is
a thing that will be you know impacted
across the entire game it's kind of
crazy to think about them doing that
like I was actually rather impressed by
how quickly they managed to change the
combat because okay obviously there are
not sort of like it's a bubble of that
area you know but you don't have to then
QA every single instance of what you've
changed across the entire game again
think about this way you know there are
bridge simulators where you construct a
bridge and send a car or truck already
as playing them on the bathroom this
morning right so it's just as simple as
changing the girders on your bridge and
getting a different result right that's
it's just iteration so much of the
content creation in this game the time
is spent in things like the visual style
like how do we set up this world but
when it comes down to the things that
are programmed the things based on hard
numbers such as the flow and speed of
combat that's the thing that really is
just iterating certain variables you
have to balance it there in a make sure
look like you know one of those girders
that was like or let's just say like a
piece of land that was in this game that
wasn't really set perfectly right but
this version this build worked yeah like
maybe when you change one of those
variables it suddenly it all falls apart
again like it kind of waited like if
they've got all the content on it then
they're like tweaking all these systems
I'm not saying it's like a watertight
system right like and every game is
different in this regard but if you
really think about it they're not having
to change every single combat scenario
one by one by one by one by one yeah
they got a QA tester stuff and you can
break things very easily but at the same
time if they do it incremental steps
there's a good chance that they can
actually iterate in a in a logical sound
way that won't break the game
interesting it's been a fascinating
road for developments looking forward to
seeing it at 2016 one question about
that you asked him a one-stage when the
original what they were originally
targeting was no during the interview I
just make that up I think he made her
just make that up my making up things
again didn't it want they said when they
announced 13 and verses 13 and a GTO
which became type 0 that they wanted
them all to come out i think it was like
around the same time yeah that sounds
about right i think if we look at this
now like at 2012 things started over all
other previous statements made didn't
hold water anymore and based on what
tabata told me which is in line with his
description of his own strengths is when
he took over the project then the
timeline was set that's what i was ten
sorry within that time line there
exactly where they hoped to be to hit
that release date which he told me was
before 2017 cool so i can only assume
that he's not lying to me because i'm a
trustworthy guy and maybe that's am I
guess I'll find out soon enough x-ray
korea peter brian thank you very much
coming on at 2016 for Final Fantasy 15
let us know if you think it's gonna come
out there in the comments below and then
check back in and say 18 months and see
if you were right or if you were wrong
you will probably wrong